Standby.
Is the Nicholl Committee ready?
Great, letting them in now.
Connected.
There she is.
Hello, Jane.
Hi, Kate.
Hello, Beth.
Hi Vanar, how are you?
I'm well, how are you?
Oh my!
So many people.
I'm Jennifer Yuh Nelson, I'm the
chair of the Nicholl Fellowship
Committee.
And I'm here with other members
of the Nicholl Committee
who read your script.
You have won a
Nicholl Fellowship.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
OK, I'm going to stop
having a panic attack now.
Thank you.
Gosh, thank you so much.
This is the best news
I've ever received.
Sorry, it feels like I just
got kicked in the brain.
Whoa, I have Bounty.
I have paper towels
in my armpits.
I can't even describe it.
It doesn't feel real.
It feels very
validating to compete
with some great writers.
Thank you for recognizing
"Sins of My Father."
That is the biggest thing.
This is such a meaningful
thing coming from the Academy
and from all of you.
You just keep
writing and writing
and then one day you're heard.
I want to thank
you for hearing me.
Thank you for your
work and good luck.
Have a great rest of
your day and stay safe.
Wear those masks!
Wow.
Uh...
oh crap, I'm still on.
I'm going to go.
Bye!
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome everyone.
I'm David Rubin, President of
the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences.
As a casting director,
of course I'm
thrilled by uncovering
exciting new acting talent.
But I think what excites me
and my fellow Academy members
most is the discovery of new
stories and new storytellers.
The mission of the Academy's
Nicholl Fellowships
in Screenwriting is to
lift up new storytellers
and to champion their talent.
Today, that mission
resonates more than ever.
Now in its 35th year,
the Nicholl competition
received a record 7,831
submissions from across the US
and over 70 countries, including
248 colleges and universities.
Their stories were read by 79
professional script readers,
including those trained in
our diverse reader training
workshop.
Next, 207 members of the
Academy winnowed down
this multifaceted collection.
And then our incomparable
Nicholl Fellowships Committee,
chaired by Short Films
and Feature Animation
governor, Jennifer Yuh Nelson,
and including Writers Branch
Governor, Larry Karaszewski, and
former Academy President, John
Bailey, made the
final selections.
In the end, the committee
embraced five winning stories.
It is these five screenplays
and the writers behind them
that we celebrate now.
Vanar Jaddou, Kate Marks,
James Acker, Jane Therese,
and Beth Curry.
To begin our program,
I'm excited to introduce
our host, Aldis Hodge.
His remarkable acting talent
has lit up screens big and small
in a broad ranging body of work.
Watch for him soon in
the role of Jim Brown,
in Academy Award
winner Regina King's
directorial debut
"One Night in Miami."
Aldis, the Nicholl
story is in your hands.
Take it away.
Thank you, David.
Welcome everyone to the
2020 Nicholl Fellowships
in Screenwriting
Awards and Table Read.
Now as an actor, a
host, and an advocate,
I'm blessed with the opportunity
to help tell amazing stories.
And today, I'm joined by an
incredible collection of talent
as we celebrate five new
storytellers and the Nicholl
Fellowship winning screenplays.
The directors of our show,
Burlee and Abel Vang,
are the writing, directing
team that won the 2011 Nicholl
Fellowship for their
screenplay, "The Tiger's Child."
They just wrapped
post-production
on their most recent feature
film, "They Live in the Gray."
Our fellow actors are
Lou Diamond Phillips.
Lou's trailblazing body of
work as an actor, director,
and author includes
performances as Don Lucho
in "The 33," about the
Chilean miners trapped
for 69 days in 2010.
Stephanie Beatriz currently
stars as Detective Rosa Diaz
on NBC's Golden Globe
award-winning comedy,
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
Michael Pena.
A Chicagoan and first generation
Mexican-American, Michael
has enthralled
audiences in turns
such as Mike Zavala
in "End of Watch"
and as Kiki Camarena in
Netflix's "Narcos" franchise.
Rounding out our cast
is Taylor Russell.
Taylor starred as Emily in
the breakout film "Waves"
for which she was honored with
the Virtuoso Award at the 2020
Santa Barbara International
Film Festival.
Through the power
of their stories,
the five new Nicholl Fellows,
Vanar, James, Jane, Kate,
and Beth helped
bring us together.
Let's meet them.
James Acker is a
2020 Nicholl Fellow.
His winning screenplay
is "SadBoi."
The script chronicles the
trials of an emotionally stunted
highschooler who, after being
thrown out of his house,
must revisit old
friends and repair
burnt bridges while searching
for a place to sleep.
James grew up in New
Jersey and Tennessee.
He's compelled to write
coming of age stories
from different perspectives.
He powerfully notes that
stories like "SadBoi"
weren't really being told
when he was growing up.
So he penned his
Nicholl winning effort
to explore some of
the harder lessons
that so many queer youth have to
learn at an all too early age.
Here's James in his own words.
When I was in the fifth
grade, I was in trouble a lot.
But the one thing I could
never mess up was writing.
For me, I just love
writing in the YA pocket.
I really like talking about
what kids go through, especially
through the high school years.
They're allowed to feel
everything all the time.
And from that, I got to
"SadBoi" just because it's
sort of an amalgamation
of all of these things
since high school.
I kept a lot inside back then.
And when trying to dig
deep, a lot of those things
come back out.
And I feel like oftentimes,
especially in youth stories
with queer characters,
a lot of the time it's
rooted in some severe abuse.
And it was really
important to me
to show just a nice,
innocent summer romance.
In this scene from
my script "SadBoi,"
an emotionally stunted
runaway, Edgar Bisset,
dreams of a quiet
afternoon with his best
friend Peter, his
only confidant,
before everything in
his life fell apart.
Exterior, the duplex evening.
Edgar, 16, sits on his porch.
He ices his eye with a
bag of frozen cauliflower.
Peter sits with him, holding
the yellow backpack in his lap.
They wait in silence.
A man and a woman scream
at each other somewhere
inside the duplex.
Peter looks at Edgar,
there's blood behind his bag.
I think you need more
than cauliflower.
Edgar stares at the
front lawn, blank.
Eddie, you need to see a doctor.
Edgar fiddles with a pebble.
The screaming inside increases.
Peter looks at the duplex
and shakes his head.
You didn't deserve that.
We don't gotta talk about it.
We should though.
Well, I don't want to.
But we talk about
everything, Eddie.
I don't want to talk
about everything.
OK.
I ask you something you
don't want to talk about.
"Cauliflower."
Edgar thinks on it, then nods.
Have you told anyone?
No.
Is it always an alcohol thing?
Always.
Does it happen a lot?
Why?
Cauliflower.
I'm sorry.
We'll do it at my step
mom's next time, OK?
It's better.
If you still-- I mean, I
really wanted you to have fun,
I'm sorry.
It was fun, Eddie.
I had a really nice trip.
The last hour was weird, but
overall still an A minus.
Yeah.
Your house is better.
You should come over.
It's just two hours away.
My parents would
love to see you.
They miss you.
Yeah, sure.
I bet my school bus would take
me to Brooklyn if I asked nice,
right?
Is it such a crazy thought?
Coming to stay.
It'd be sick.
No one would mess with
me with you around.
What?
People are still
messing with you?
It's just what they do.
Who am I to stop
people from having fun?
Oh, you shouldn't let
people fuck with you, Peter.
You need to respect yourself.
Peter makes a face.
They sit in this obvious irony.
You really think
I could help you?
Is that so hard to believe?
I don't know.
Sometimes I feel like I only
make things worse, you know?
I make people worse.
Horse shit, Edgar.
Without you, I never
would've tried wearing hats.
You do look good in hats.
We help each other.
If you move to New York,
we'd help each other.
Yeah.
And how would you help me?
I'd help people to get
to know you, get to like
you, the real you.
You saying I'm not likeable?
No.
Your face is.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
Don't make me laugh.
OK, don't make me leave.
Peter smiles.
Edgar smiles back.
They relax for a moment and
look up at the trees slowly
dropping leaves.
Peter sighs.
I mean, come on.
That's not beautiful
to you, Eddie?
They both get lost in the sight.
Peter takes Edgar's hand.
You think you'll come to
the beach again this summer?
A trail of melted
ice and blood drips
from the bag of cauliflower
and down Edgar's face.
He notices it and
his body tenses.
His breathing catches.
He tries to stay calm.
Yeah, Pete?
Peter sees Edgar getting upset.
Hey.
Hey, do you you think, um--
could they pick you
up down the street?
Could you go down the street?
I don't, I don't--
I mean, um.
Edgar.
A tear drops from
Edgar's good eye.
Please?
Pete, please?
I mean, they can't--
Edgar stands up and looks
away fighting back tears.
Peter stands and gets close.
Edgar backs away.
No, come on.
Just stop.
I just-- I don't
want him to see me.
I'm no-- I don't want to like--
Edgar drops the bag, faces
the wall and hangs his head.
Peter turns him around
and holds on to him.
Edgar buries his face
into Peter's shoulder
and chokes back sobs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I mean, I didn't
do anything, man.
I didn't even do anything.
What the fuck is
wrong with me, Pete?
What the fuck is wrong with me?
Peter rubs Edgar's head close.
Nothing.
Nothing is wrong
with you, Edgar.
Nothing.
Edgar hugs him back.
Peter whispers in his ear.
Leaves fall.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Jane Therese is a
2020 Nicholl Fellow.
Her winning screenplay
is "Sins of my Father."
Based on a true
story, the script
follows a young woman in Ireland
who grapples with the love
that she has for her
father after bringing
charges of abuse against him,
which shatters a country.
Jane is a photojournalist
who's covered stories ranging
from a democracy
uprising in Haiti
to the events of
September 11, 2001.
As a writer, she scripted
"Sins of My Father"
to give voice to an
epidemic of abuse that
impacts families in Ireland,
as well as communities
across the globe.
Here's Jane in her own words.
I've been storytelling all of
my life in different formats.
I love screenwriting
and I love to be
able to express myself that way.
So I was in the
Athena Lab in 2019
and we were having a
roundtable discussion
on the behavioral
characteristics of a predator.
96% of victims recognize
their predator.
They've been coaxed,
they've been manipulated,
they've been persuaded
all under the distorted
guise of love and trust.
So what I wanted to do with
our protagonist, Imogen,
was come from the experiences
of the child within her.
The scene that you're
about ready to hear
takes place inside
the courthouse.
Imogen, her sister,
and her husband
are sequestered in a side room.
This is the day
that Imogen is going
to be able to address the
judge for the first time.
In walks the investigator
and a social worker
to discuss what
actually is going to be
said inside the courtroom.
This is the first time Imogen
realizes the consequences
of her actions
and that nobody is
going to be leaving unscathed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Interior courthouse
witness suite.
A sequestered room
with no windows.
There is coffee,
tea, and danish.
A couch, table and chairs,
magazines, bathroom,
and a clock.
Everything one could want
while awaiting their fate.
So help yourself to anything.
It'll be a bit of a wait.
I do want to prepare you so that
there's no misunderstandings.
It's just a bit nerve wracking.
Imogen is having a
minor panic attack.
Deep breaths.
Barrett softens.
You're doing fine, Imogen.
Yeah, right.
It's not you who has to show
your face afterwards, is it?
No, no it's not.
Imogen, your
father's defense will
try to plead a motion
for continuance
binding your father's
medical records.
Imogen and Colleen scoff.
They won't get it.
Excuse me?
I can't go through this again.
This is happening
today if I have
to follow the judge into
the jacks to plead my case.
Let's just hope it
doesn't come to that.
Relax, I'll be right back.
[DOOR CLOSES]
Barrett leaves.
It's just Eamon, Colleen,
and Imogen alone.
Eamon tries a danish.
He approves, offering
one to Imogen.
No, my stomach is all twisted.
Oh, the nerve of him.
Imogen lights a cigarette.
Eamon fills his plate and sits.
Anxiety grows.
Collen pulls a pot brownie
from her coat pocket
and picks at it.
Eamon eyes her.
You want some to
take the edge off?
She breaks off a piece,
handing it to Eamon,
only to have Imogen swoop
down and squash the morsel.
Jesus.
What the fuck?
Giving me a bloody heart attack.
This is maddening enough without
you bringing your dope in here.
OK, OK, OK.
We hold on the
three for what seems
like an endless amount of time.
Imogen shoots
Eamon the evil eye.
He begs forgiveness by
making another offer of food.
Imogen and picks up the
magazine, looking through it.
She sets it down in paces.
Colleen takes a small drawing
pad and pencil from her purse
and sketches.
We feel the strain.
Imogen picks at her scab.
The clock's second
hand jerks forward,
catching Imogen's attention.
She watches it tick
around its circumference.
Enter Barrett and Erin Lawlor.
Imogen brightens.
How are you, Imogen?
I'll be representing the
sexual assault victims
unit on your case.
How much longer?
He'll plead, then we
go right to sentencing.
Imogen's now uncomfortable
with the idea.
Colleen wraps her
arm around an Imogen,
pulling her body towards
her for reassurance.
Hey, this is what
you wanted, right?
Interior courthouse
witness suite, same.
Barrett sits at the table
and opens his briefcase.
He lays out a redacted
copy of her statement.
So I'm going to jump right in.
Your victim impact statement,
you mentioned Eugene's death.
My dad's the reason
Gene killed himself.
He was tormented.
OK.
Your father wants that removed.
Why?
Eugene would be here
if it weren't for him.
He confessed to us.
Jean couldn't stand
him after what he did.
Well, there's no absolute proof
he wouldn't have turned out
like that on his own.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I bet.
Are you joking me, man?
Ladies, I have no
control over this.
Let's keep the focus on
Imogen. The cemetery.
Balking at the absurdity,
Colleen flinches.
Fucking me on his mom
and pop's grave too
sacrilegious for him now?
What good is the
victim's statement when
I can't use the bloody thing?
Erin soothes Imogen.
And the time at Killiney Beach?
Killiney too.
Imogen throws your hands up.
For God's sake, man.
If I don't sit, I will
surely walk out of here
and kill him with my own hands.
Then there won't be
a need for a trial.
Tell him that.
We have enough evidence, Imogen.
It's just the statement is all.
There is one more thing.
For the love of God.
Ane.
What about Ane?
The courts have your records.
He petitioned for
them, remember?
She's right.
This is her doing.
Barrett notices the
time on the clock.
We need to go.
Please, Detective, you
can't say anything.
I spoke in confidence.
Tell him anything else.
I'm sorry, Imogen,
it's out of our hands.
You want him to
go to jail, right?
Barrett holds the door
open for the women.
Colleen lovingly puts
her arm around Imogen,
leading her into the
courthouse hallway
where Eamon is waiting with
a slew of news journalists.
The barrage of news
crew flood Imogen. Eamon
rushes to her side.
Barrett escorts them
inside the courtroom.
Reporters follow.
[PHOTOS SNAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Story is everything.
It can make one person laugh or
it can light up a crowded room.
It can give voice to a
community or speak the truth
of a town, a city, a nation.
It can bring the
difficult past to life
and imagine the best
possible future.
Story is everything.
But nothing unless they include
all voices, especially yours.
For 35 years, the Academy
Nicholl Fellowships
in Screenwriting has
lifted up storytellers
and championed
inclusive storytelling.
Over 170 Nicholl
Fellowships have
been awarded since the
program began in 1986.
Nicholl Fellows have
gone on to become
some of the most impactful
storytellers in film.
Becoming a Nicholl
Fellow means the start
of an incredible journey
to tell you a story,
to write a feature
length screenplay,
to mentor with Academy members
and receive a $35,000 cash
prize.
And today, we're
surrounded by stories
of unprecedented trial, triumph,
and everything in between.
What makes your story
new, different, and unique
is more fierce, necessary,
and urgent than ever.
Your story can entertain,
educate, empower.
You can do all that and more.
Your story can change the world.
And the world needs to hear you.
Now more than ever.
Start your journey
today in oscars.org.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Vanar Jaddou is a
2020 Nicholl fellow.
His winning screenplay
is "Goodbye, Iraq."
Inspired by true
events, the script
chronicles the struggles
of a paranoid ex-solider,
and his fiery daughter who
flee from Iraq to the US
while they're hunted by Saddam
Hussein's ruthless regime.
The son of brave
refugees from Iraq, Vanar
was galvanized to
write "Goodbye, Iraq"
by the stories of
his grandfather,
as well as the mostly unheard
voices of many Kurdish
and Chaldean immigrants.
Here's Vanar in his own words.
I've been screenwriting
for about nine years.
When I was young, my mom
would make me and my brothers
either draw or
write a short story
before we went outside
to play sports.
And I think that's where
imagination and originality
were born for me.
And my dad, he had
a small video store
where I used to work
on the weekends.
And by the time I was 15,
I had seen more movies
than was probably healthy
for a teenage kid.
There were so many untold
and undocumented stories
that my father, and grandfather,
my mom had about Iraq
in their village.
There was so much joy there,
but there's also a lot of pain
and a lot of horror.
I wanted to write something
that was set in that world.
In this scene from
"Goodbye, Iraq,"
Manzin and Noor, a
father and daughter
on the run from Saddam's
forces, have narrowly
escaped death from a missile and
cocktail of chemical weapons.
Now in a mosque with
other survivors,
but a place with none
of their own people,
they must attempt to regather
themselves and determine
who should and
shouldn't be trusted
as they begin their
dangerous refuge to America.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Interior.
Mosque, Badinan countryside day.
Kurds clean wounds, use
oxygen tanks to breathe,
perform small surgeries.
Many blistered and
swollen from the cocktail
of gas and chemicals.
Even more are blind.
They pray.
Mahzen slumps, pellet
lodged in his left shoulder.
Cuts caked in blood.
Road burns.
Past scars etched
like railroad tracks.
Noor stares wide-eyed
at his wounds.
Should I get someone
else to do it?
Noor wipes away a
tear, grabs a bottle
of Arak (liquor)
laying around and pours
some on Mahzen's shoulder.
Fresh blood splashes
out of the hole.
As Noor preps a needle and
thread, her focus sharpens.
Hold still.
She sews into the
skin above the pellet.
Mom teach you this?
Yeah.
Tugs a thread.
He grimaces.
She pulls it through.
You remind me so much of her.
Most of our people,
they're very conservative.
But your mom was adventurous.
Noor smiles.
She refocuses on his wound.
Thank you for earlier,
for telling me the truth.
You deserve to know.
Ahead, Peshmerga huddle,
dressed in desert camouflage.
We have to leave,
we can't fight gas.
And bullets, we can
dodge no longer.
They will come
for the survivors.
We must get these
people to Turkey.
Noor listens in as Mazin
digs into his backpack
for something.
By nightfall, these
villages will all be bombed.
They have families
too, where we're
going, hiding in the mountains.
Noor fidgets with the needle
unnerved, both at the violence
and how privy he is to it.
Manzin uncaps a pill bottle
and pops an antibiotic.
It doesn't have to be like that.
There doesn't have to
be violence everywhere
all the time.
Noor, these people are
fighting for their freedom,
for their own.
Well, that's not living.
As Mahzen considers that, a
red wizened face in a hijab
scuffles into the dim light.
Roza.
She speaks Arabic.
I wanted to see how
you two were doing.
How bad is it?
Mahzen observes her.
The deep cracks on her
forehand and around her eyes
are smeared with dust.
He's had worse.
Roza hands Mahzen
a canteen of water.
He assesses her.
Her hijab.
Doesn't accept.
It's dangerous to be
a Kurd in this world.
To come to these villages,
it's irresponsible.
Mahzen surveys the mosque.
Kurds vomit blood.
Some of their skin
starting to blister.
Eyes beginning to bleed.
Why don't you worry
about your own people?
She understands his English, but
continues to respond in Arabic.
Don't you have any sense?
Look, we're just
passing through.
Passing through.
I see.
So you're him.
Mahzen stares at her like a
predator caught off guard.
He scans the mosque as if
waiting for a slew of hyenas
to encircle him.
That's good enough, Noor.
But I'm not done yet.
It's fine.
Knot it.
Noor pulls the strings
end, brings as much flesh
as she can together
before knotting it.
Mahzen wipes his body
with his ripped shirt,
slips it on, throws
a bomber over it.
Where are you going?
America.
Noor.
Mahzen glowers at her.
He forces the oversized
bulletproof vest over her shirt
then grabs her arm.
Let's go.
You should be careful who
sees you out of this country.
They may have other ideas when
they find out who you are.
The Peshmerga will take
us over the mountain.
Then what?
You have to get to Greece
to get off his radar.
What is it that you want?
Just to help.
As you tried to do for us all.
As your daughter did for me.
Roza motions for them to
follow then walks ahead.
I trust her.
We don't know her.
Noor follows Roza,
leaving Mahzen
to deliberate on his own.
Beth Curry is a
2020 Nicholl Fellow.
Her winning
screenplay is "Lemon."
The script explores the trials
of a 5-year-old girl who,
after the death of her
agoraphobic mother,
ventures outside for the first
time in search of her father.
Beth is a former
Broadway performer.
While on tour with
"Young Frankenstein"
and sitting backstage wearing
a Bride of Frankenstein wig,
Beth wrote one of
her first scripts.
She believes more
than ever that stories
need to make a difference by
lifting up voices that have
gone unheard for far too long.
Here's Beth in her own words.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I first got into writing.
I was on the National tour
of "Young Frankenstein"
playing the Madeleine Khan.
And I would do a number
in the first act.
And then I would go
offstage for an hour.
And then one day
I started writing.
The feeling I had at the
end of it was so fulfilling.
And so from that moment
on, I was addicted.
My mission as a writer is to
tell stories and give voice
to characters that
don't have a voice
or to tell stories that
haven't been told yet.
And just have a little
more kindness for somebody
that you don't understand.
So this is a scene
from "Lemon" where
Lemon is having pancakes
with her social worker
and with Michael.
And she's affectionately
named him Fluffy Head.
She wants to be
adopted by Fluffy Head,
and it's very clear to her
that they belong together,
whereas he has suffered
a lot of loss in his life
and wants a little distance
even though he's really
drawn to Lemon.
And they have an
undeniable connection.
So this is a scene
where their desires
are in conflict over pancakes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Interior, Sheila's
office, hours later.
[RINGING]
Sheila's phone rings.
Asleep on her desk, she
wakes up at the start.
She groggily answers.
Hello?
She looks over to
where Lemon was.
She's gone.
She runs out of the
office looking for Lemon.
Hold on.
She runs out of the office.
She asks an officer.
Where's Lemon?
He points around the corner.
She sees Lemon with PJ, four.
The girl laughing, pretending
to talk into Pip's old phone.
Sheila lets out a
big sigh of relief.
I'm sorry, who is this again?
Exterior park, continuous.
Michael sits on a bench
as he talks to Sheila.
Intercut call.
Hi, it's Michael Archer.
Lemon was in my closet.
Oh, hi.
How are you doing?
I'm still a little overwhelmed.
Uh-huh, I can imagine.
Paul at the police
station gave me a card.
And I know this is weird, but I
just wanted to check on Lemon.
Well, she's been asking for you.
She has?
Oh yes.
It's Fluffy Head this
and Fluffy Head that.
Fluffy Head, yeah.
That's funny.
I, uh, I was just wondering
if I could meet you
both for breakfast sometime?
How about today?
Interior Pancake Pals
Restaurant, moments later.
Lemon is poised over her
chocolate chip pancakes
in her protective gear.
Her scarf is pushed
down around her neck.
And so I ran away
because she's mean
and she might steal my soul.
Ellen is not going
to steal your soul.
Lemon's mom was
agoraphobic and she
conditioned Lemon to
fear going outside saying
people would steal her soul.
You knew?
I am aware of that.
I am just filling Michael in.
Fluffy Head!
Fluffy Head.
I'm not going to get
away from that, am I?
No.
Anyway, Ellen yells and
she throws things around.
Your foster mother?
Those are very strong
accusations, Lemon.
Well, I hid in the
closet and asked Hyla
and she told me that
I'll get used to it.
But I don't want
to get used to it.
A waiter comes up to the table.
Can I get you anything else?
Upon seeing him, Lemon puts
up her scarf around her mouth
and puts her head on the table.
How are those chocolate
chip pancakes?
Lemon remains hidden.
They were great.
Mmm.
We'll just take the bill.
The waiter tears off the bill
and leaves it on the table.
Is he gone?
He's gone.
Lemon looks up again.
Lemon, no one is
going to steal--
You don't know that.
OK, it hasn't happened yet.
So maybe it won't happen.
Or maybe it will.
Sheila and Michael
exchange a look.
Well, what if-- what
if I live with you?
Like for reals.
Oh God, no.
I-- I mean, I just wanted
to meet up and say hi.
I didn't mean for you to
misconstrue my intentions.
I just wanted to
check up on you and--
You're saying a lot of big words
but all you need to say is yes.
Lemon.
I'm just-- I'm not in the
space right now to, um--
Please, I can't go
back to Ellen's.
Lemon, we need to let
Michael have some time.
He's been through a lot.
But I've been through a lot too.
We both need hugs.
Why can't I live with you?
You're good, you saved that
bird, you won't steal my soul.
Please.
Please!
I'm sorry, Lemon.
I wish I could help.
I'm going to go pay the bill.
Lemon lays her head
down on the table.
Michael looks at
Sheila apologetically
as he walks to the counter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Kate Marks is a
2020 Nicholl Fellow.
Her winning screenplay
is "The Cow of Queens."
The coming of age drama explores
how a young woman and her dying
father struggle to save
an escaped slaughterhouse
cow running for its life
on the streets of Queens.
Kate loves to tell stories
that flip from hilarious
to heartbreaking.
Her deep desire to
use humor and strength
to confront and
confound grief and loss
is what helped to inspire
"The Cow of Queens."
Here's Kate in her own words.
I started out writing plays,
but the very first short
that I made, I felt
like I was able to get
inside the character in a
way that I had never been
able to do as a playwright.
"The Cow of Queens" is
inspired by two very different,
but both true stories about
the fight to stay alive.
The first one comes from my dad.
My dad was my best friend.
So when he got sick, I
couldn't leave his side.
So after he died, I was
haunted by these questions.
When do you fight?
When do you accept?
And how do you say goodbye?
And then I heard
about a cow that
escaped a local
slaughterhouse and had
a field day running
from the police
on the streets of Queens.
I started to imagine my dad
and I as Don Quixote and Sancho
Panza chasing an impossible
dream on a mission
to right one last wrong
and save this cow.
In this scene, you're going to
meet father, daughter duo Del
and Sonya, in the midst
of a very rough morning
after a very rough night
dealing with Del's failing body.
They are just about to leave
for a doctor's appointment
where they are going to get
the results of Del's PET scan
and learn whether the last
round of chemo worked.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Interior kitchen, morning.
You ready?
I just got to iron my pants.
We don't have time.
I don't want to get bad
news in wrinkled pants.
Can we please just wait to
hear what Dr. Schlossberg says?
That guy's about as
useful as tits on a bull.
Come on.
I don't need some damn scan to
tell me parts are falling off.
Sonya pushes the
eggs toward Del.
It's cause you're not eating.
No, it's cause I'm getting
the shit kicked out of me.
Del shakes his head.
Have one bite, at least.
We're out of ketchup.
Sonya whips out a bottle
and squirts a giant glob
on the plate.
I can't.
Sonya scoops up the eggs.
They jiggle on the spoon as
she brings them to Del's mouth.
Jesus Christ, I'm not a baby.
Del locks his lips shut.
You have to get
something in your system.
He slowly takes a bite.
Thank you.
He holds the food in his cheeks.
Come on.
Silence.
Swallow it.
He tries, but it
comes right back up.
[SPITTING]
Sonya slams a
spoon on the table.
I told you, I can't do it.
Sonya feels like she's
about to throw up.
I'm sorry, sweet.
Sonya rushes out.
We're going to be late.
Interior hallway, 10:30 AM.
Del and Sonya stare down
a long set of stairs.
Del leans on Sonya who's also
got a folded up wheelchair.
Del whistles, they take
it one step at a time
as they begin
their slow descent.
A busy woman, 30s, races past
them with a mug of coffee,
clicking in bright
red scuffed heels.
Blisters forming.
A couple of drops of
coffee splash out.
They round the second landing
passing a fighting couple.
A woman screams.
Del stands at attention.
It's nothing.
How do you know?
They do this all the time.
Del looks back.
The argument sounds like
the end of the world
and it hits him hard.
Exterior, street, moments later.
Sonya pushes Del
in a wheelchair.
Humiliated, he pulls
his hat over his eyes
as they pass a friendly face.
Exterior side
street, continuous.
Del notices the new route.
What are you doing?
Shortcut.
Newspapers swirl in the wind.
Del backs them away.
Just ahead, they
pass a homeless woman
wrangling the storm
of loose newspapers
back into her plastic bags.
Sonya?
She looks up to see a brown
cow flash across the sidewalk
and disappear into
a nearby alley.
Del and Sonya skid to a stop.
What?
They turn to see Ralph, 37, a
heavy butcher sprinting around
the corner in white work
clothes splattered with blood.
He stops, sweaty
and out of breath.
His beard curls up,
giving him the appearance
of the perfect villain.
You didn't have to see a
cow come this way, did you?
Um.
No.
Ralph eyes Del.
Del calmly folds his
hands in his lap.
You sure about that?
A cow?
Yes.
I don't think we'd miss
something like that.
A cow?
Right, Sonya?
Right.
Ralph studies Sonya.
She's clearly hiding something.
They stare each other
down and it takes
everything she has to hold on.
He steps a step
closer toward her,
entering her force
field of pain.
Sadness wafts off
like a bad smell.
She closes her eyes and shakes
her head teetering on the edge.
Ralph looks to Del.
She just broke up
with her boyfriend.
Dad.
OK, boss.
OK.
Ralph looks left,
looks right, and takes
off as fast as he can.
Del waits for him to clear
the corner then looks down
the alley.
A trashcan rattles.
Del rises and walks
stiffly toward the sound.
Sonya starts to fold
up the wheelchair.
Leave it.
She parks the chair at
the edge of the alley.
Exterior alley, continuous.
The cow rummages
through bags of trash.
Sensing Del and Sonya, it
pops its head up and freezes.
Del inches closer.
Should we?
Shhh...
Words have no place here.
Del and the cow
stare eye to eye.
He takes his hat
off in reverence.
The cow blinks at Del.
Hi, friend.
Del smiles softly.
The two share a breath.
The cow's nostrils
are soft and moist.
And then...
It jets, trotting
away like a unicorn.
Del limps a couple
of steps after it.
Don't let them
take you, Comrade!
The cow gallops around a corner.
Resist!
Del looks back to Sonya.
His eyes are lit up with magic.
Do you think it'll make it?
Anything's possible.
With that, our event
draws to a close.
Made possible by the awesome
creative contributions
of Burlee and Abel Vang
and the distinctive voices
of Lou Diamond Phillips.
Stay safe and healthy.
Stephanie Beatriz, Michael
Pena, and Taylor Russell,
and the Academy
Nicholl Fellowships
in Screenwriting team.
We also shout out a special
note of love and support
to the Nicholl Fellowships in
Screenwriting Committee whose
leadership and energy guided
the 2020 screenwriting
competition to this moment of
culmination and celebration.
And now to all of you who tuned
in and got involved today.
As we get ready to hit fade
out on our time together,
I've got a question for you.
How have Vanar,
Kate, Jane, James,
and Beth's story spoken to you?
Are you inspired?
More determined than ever?
Do you see yourself
in their dedication?
Do you see yourself in
their stories, characters,
and conflicts?
Surprises and revelations?
Do they help you
feel seen and heard?
We hope so.
We hope to hear your
story very, very soon.
And maybe this time
next year, we'll
be celebrating your story.
To get started, please
visit oscars.org.
Thank you, take
care, and stay safe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]